[Music]
Kristen Stewart opening up about her
sexuality and falling in love
it's bold to do that it's courageous to
give yourself to someone like that so
yeah I did that in a new interview the
27 year old actress dishes on her dating
history telling Harper's Bazaar UK she
has a positive outlook on her past quote
I've been deeply in love with everyone
I've dated she adds I've always really
embraced a duality and really truly
believed in it and never felt confused
or struggling I know people love to say
like oh she doesn't give up like no I
totally do men
you'll recall Kristen has been in
several high-profile romances over the
years she dated singer st. Vincent her
Twilight co-star Robert Pattinson and
has recently been spotted getting cozy
with model Stella Maxwell Kristen has
steered clear of getting romantically
involved with men in recent years but
admit she's open to dating guys again
quote yeah totally some people know that
they like grilled cheese and they'll eat
it every day for the rest of their lives
I want to try everything
[Music]
you